all right
just gotta make sure somebody's okay
Drake pauses his concert after a fan
falls from a balcony
[Music]
yeah according to reports the fall
happened 90 minutes into the rapper show
at New York sees Apollo Theater just
moments after he welcomed rapper 21
Savage to the stage
the audience member fell from the lower
mezzanine and landed in the orchestra
all right
got to make sure somebody's okay that's
when the house lights went up and Drake
stopped his performance to check on
everyone you know I'm about unity and
spreading love a rep for the Apollo
Theater released a statement after the
accident revealing that the venue Drake
and SiriusXM halted the show immediately
and standard protocols were taken
paramedics checked out the fan and other
audience members who all ended up being
okay with no major injuries the concert
was stopped for about 15 minutes before
resuming
[Music]
Drake made his highly anticipated
appearance at the Apollo over the
weekend after the show was postponed
Twice first back in November after the
death of Drake's friend Migos rapper
takeoff whenever he would take his
Shades off he had this thing about him
that I love no matter what was going on
around us he was like always
kind of squinting but like his eyes were
wide open then again in December due to
production issues
[Music]
the two night show was packed with fans
as the rapper performed his biggest hits
when I'm performing you know as Drake
you know at concerts in different cities
I always like to bring that character to
the stage and it was a star-studded
weekend celeb fans like Justin and Haley
Bieber were in attendance as well as
ASAP Ferg and Kevin Durant and if you
missed the Big Show you can catch it
when it airs on Drake's exclusive
SiriusXM channel sound 42.
[Music]
fill me up and uh who I need
to see me
[Music]